today something very special happens it
is the finale of the Sam and Nico
Channel 2016 and in this episode one
unlucky person will have to shave will
it be Ben or Brett I don't know but
there's been a lot of feuding there's
been a lot of talk we're gonna do a
beard off the loser has to shave it's
real neither ever want to but one of
them will the stakes are real the
competition is fierce
I'm the beard judge I'm here to separate
the men from the boys
the determine who goes first we're gonna
do an arm wrestling competition three
two one go it's beers very cheap
it's a dad guys friends doesn't rush got
the muzzle but bill got the light
what are you working on bread oh man
just uh getting the Darth Santa costume
laid out the chute sure you know how I
played Darth Senate last year yeah yeah
well I'd like you to play it this year
well this is a pretty big promotion for
you quite frankly you're gonna look like
a badass I'll see it okay catch you
later
today we are shooting darts Santa
strikes back we're gonna have kylo Ren
team up with darsana they're gonna go
around you know do what they do best
which is destroy Christmas for everyone
else hi Brett played our Santa today and
I'm really happy that he's liking it
because I didn't want to tell him that
it really sucks being in the costume but
it seems like he's really actually
enjoying it which great for me great for
him you know everyone wins rough stuff
some rough stuff so much fun having too
much
do your faces today all right all right
all right all right we got to give that
one to bed let's go what that
armwrestling comforter is any indication
of how the rest of this is going to go
it's a doozy a pinnacle of manhood has
been to know where true north is at any
given time well here we need to know
where true West is whoever is able to
point to do west winds all right hold on
down I'm gonna kill you at Point less on
thing did it morning come on ready and 3
2 1 Koya stop aah
you try man
good try number 2 chopping wood
whoever splits it more evenly down the
middle and wins since Brent when he gets
to choose which piece of wood he wants
to split
snowy weather side
the chapel for hours
I don't know
[Applause]
colorful okay what's happening so I'm
trying to think about how to make this
shot that we're doing nastier which is
Darth Vader and kylo Ren putting coal
into Christmas gifts which is you know
pretty sinister what makes it really
sinister is a live scorpion being
dropped into one of them all you come
here buddy
you're gonna stand right here it's not
he right I'm glad don't think no I can't
see it I know I'm trying to frame it up
so first it's the scorpion accidentally
falls on the ground I will handle it
okay no one do anything other than get
out of its way you see this I mean yeah
I just reach in there pinching by the
tail okay do it do it try to do it fast
thinking my fingers in there there you
go you got it hold them tight you move
all them tighten it look like bullseye
don't panic don't have any block all
right all ready ready yeah
do it Oh God
shall be blown out calm down do it do it
yeah one more yeah
one more and then we got it all right
yeah all right okay all right God we got
it all right cool
you're doing a great job and play it
together know that you can play there
can only be one Vader I'll wear it for
like 30 minutes you can wear for like
three hours if it's Bischoff's I
wouldn't want to take that limelight
from you no you wouldn't be taking it so
we'd be shared I wouldn't feel right
about that Wow I mean yeah no I think
you're doing great we're gonna keep you
in it all right
ah what's up Kofi uh sit yeah no sigh
just covered in sweat you know what's up
[Music]
sparks fly sparks fly that's a win brent
game number three the staring contest
let's see if looks can really kill
thanks a whole my eyes open scientists
aren ourselves
buck stay on yourself yeah either one to
break face or blink losses draw Oh got a
blinker like David's are all right I
love man this round it's anyone's game
at this point being number four push-ups
whoever can do more in one minute wins
if I see any shaky limbs chop those
trees down you know what these call me
Brett will they come even Johnny pusher
go one I'll go
[Music]
all the bunnymen hologram that's 20
right there
no she'll put it this only 15 seconds to
go strong
ben-hur now - why just when you think
Ben's getting close
Bret goes and does something like that
now Bret's up three to one
but I've seen people come back to this
game number five the classic turn and
draw whoever hits the other contestant
first wins
drop no to too bad three Bret how do you
feel a mid game here completely in
control that you do so competition
number six is called shoot from the hip
whoever hits closest to the center of
the eyes wins the range is hot fire when
ready
[Music]
[Music]
second shot all right Oh
[Music]
last shot last shot that's what I call
him last chance Waller did actually hit
the targets face which the other shot
did not sudden together one this the
seventh and final round it is the last
so they will try to lasso the other
contestant and pull them off the mark
whoever does it first wins
whoever loses it has to shave Oh Oh
[Music]
wrong with you that's a wizard now you
saying
judge calm
well Fred I'm sorry free pretty painful
we can make me find you a trimmer yeah
son then you go sit down son oh what a
gentleman will he accept
the game religious uh yeah
[Music]
[Music]